[Musique]
lourdios ichère village béarnais de la
vallée d'aspe fait depuis quatre ans la
montée en estive de ses sept berges et
le calendrier pastorale a été respectée
un milieu de brebis et une cinquantaine
de vaches ont gagné les verts pâturages
des montagnes pyrénéennes la
transhumance une tradition que nous vous
proposons de redécouvrir ce soir
et c'est le temps aux bêtes de s'adapter
à l'altitude au rythme de leurs pas à 65
ans jean blaye berger de la vallée gasc
continue à se rendre avec son troupeau
de 200 brebis de la plaine de l'eau
robert lourdios ichère 25 km par la
route partie au petit jour l'as quoi
conduit ses bêtes sur la montagne du
lien vers 1500 mètres
est descendu au mois d'octobre le kaiser
le de 10h15 à demander l'aide du jour et
après à remonter au début juin
c'est la seule à faire s'il a fait
monter la remontée est bon ça
y est voilà on perd et marées
la transhumance une activité importante
en béarn 150 berger gagne les estives il
représente environ 450 éleveurs pour un
cheptel de près de 70000 brody et un
millier de vaches autre âge il pourra
pour arriver à vivre sur des petites
exploitations d'ailleurs dans la vallée
nos exploitations sont de petites
superficies et l'allée steve nous permet
de faire revivre nos bêtes ce soit des
vaches des brebis ou des chevaux pas
gratuitement mais presque pendant ces
mois de l'année ce qui nous permet de
faire des réserves fourragères la
surexploitation pour les nourrir à
suivre pendant l'hiver
rassemblés à l'entrée du village les
touristes mais aussi les habitants de la
vallée sont venus partager l'événement
les troupeaux sont marqués avant de
gagner la montagne c'est la peinture qui
est mélangée avec de la graisse ou de
l'huile a fondu si on fait chauffer et
on met une poudre à sa peinture va en
poudre a et ça fait la couleur et la
grèce permet de faire tenir et de
résister à la pluie
l'immense de montagne lourdios ichère
compte 180 habitants une population qui
vit essentiellement du pastoralisme
90% des actifs de lourdios sont des
bergers au des pasteurs des trains
j'aime avant tout cas et
nous avons encore un trente
exploitations agricoles qui sont
occupées dans ce qui n'est pas pour
séance ordinaire et puis comme vous le
voyez
l'ensemble des prairies deschamps sont
entretenus je dirais presque jardiner
[Musique]
après les chants traditionnels du groupe
berne et lous pastes où il payerait ce
les bergers du village sur des lits pour
entendre la bénédiction de leurs plus
hauts et si
il est l'heure pour les brebis de montée
en estive bataillent
depuis plusieurs saisons kirghize ya
découvre le métier à 17 ans ce fils
d'enseignants a choisi de devenir berger
envie de faire ce métier c'est une
passion pour le pour le bétail et pour
pour la montagne ça
et ça m'a pris ya quatre ans avec réjean
blaye justement elle avait voulu
m'apprendre en montagne en pleine
affaire partout aujourd'hui alors que
des jeunes se lance dans le métier est
contrainte a mené par la mise en place
du projet européen natura 2000 inquiète
on ne sait pas du tout si on va pouvoir
continuer notre métier dans les
conditions là actuellement il ya que la
pousse de l'herbe qui nous qui nous
commandent la provoc remonter au courage
et steve on ne sait pas demain ce sera
d'autres contraintes comme par exemple
la présence de nuru ou d'un aigle ou
d'un gip arrête sera sur le secteur il
faut que nous continuions à avoir la
maîtrise de nos territoires et à ce
moment là nous sommes prêts à travailler
bien sûr avec la france mais aussi avec
l'europe la condition que nous soyons
nous en position de faire
chaque saison hébergé bernie prévisions
estime 250 tonnes de fromage à nous
ayons l'européenne de kabal fait partie
des chantiers en cours le pastoralisme
une richesse vital pour l'avenir des
villages de la vallée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
début juillet la transhumance vers en
vallée d'ossau les troupeaux gagner les
autres et steve et le 13 juillet
prochain célébrera la tradition avec le
traité franco espagnole de la route de
rang car vous avez maintenant rendez
vous avec votre édition régionale
bonsoir
[Musique]